well if we thought that about 1o
comments surely we must have loved
Street Fighter oh my god now Street
Fighter I don't have any issue telling
people that I freaking hate it and it's
stupid cuz most people go oh yeah
everyone nobody gives me a hard drive by
them a Mortal Kombat yes read fighter is
like now I never I not know I've seen
things now here's the question I've
never met anyone that like Street
Fighter
oh well no one that will admit to don't
watch all everybody on YouTube I got
married to the movie street fighter how
dare you I'm just a magic and by say
like do you old hey ah I lost my
virginity by watching Street no nobody
did that no there's gotta be one dude I
don't use gotta because I've gotta be
one the only thing I can think is like
somebody accidentally rented this movie
put it on a daisy this songs you want
fuck instead yes that's what happens
still counts stores an alternative but
not to it they turn it off and then they
do it alright so Street Fighter so I
nobody admits to liking but but here's
my question
much like Mortal Kombat annihilation
would you rap
would you know you wouldn't rather watch
this the Mortal Kombat there see for me
and honestly you know what okay let me
this way it's they may be tied because
they're but they both have the same
problem they're both boring as hell okay
but this movie does have wonder your
talk about Christopher Lambert
this movie has fuckin raúl juliá as a
vice so now him but the Vaughn Dom man
answers to it is up just just him trying
to you know his that's the thing
jean-claude van damme has fought so many
enemies but he's never bested English
someone that's one enemies never gonna
take them needs his wake-up call
and busting I'm fighting for world peace
yeah no this is world peace well yes um
but but no role Julia in this movie I
pretty much dedicated my own movie -
this performed he is he is amazing I
give you this know I'm noticing bug eyes
of his and those weird poses and he's oh
baby you just came back and turned off
her life - thank you it's the room is
haunted by the ghost around Julia uh
okay here's what those people were even
if he's like if I'm gonna suck at
performance I'm gonna be in a bad movie
it is gonna be the most amazing bad
performance you've ever seen in your
life and he is just beyond entertaining
and he is he's one of those actors were
I have to every time I see him on screen
I'm like fuck I hate that he's dead like
this guy judge so much not only too soon
but that was his final me up oh no and
that's why I love at the very end like
you see like after the credits like his
hand comes out the robe on I'm like you
know I don't think I gotta hit him
what's the film dedicated to him fucking
defecating I've gotta admit those other
things were I had seen the movie like it
I was working on the film I'd be like do
you think we can remove the dedication
I'm not sure if he'd want to be
remembered for this no he'll be replayed
with Tim Curry like The Addams Family
oh no okay see you know what you know
what I wish I wish I could take certain
parts of MORTAL KOMBAT and certain for
like take Christopher Lambert for Mortal
Kombat and raúl juliá from Street
Fighter and like a couple other things
of mish mash them together cuz it's hard
to pick which enemy right street fighter
does have we're all Juliette it has um
from Chen Lee Han I just always was a
chun-li fan um see I thought you would
hate it because uh she was pretty but I
mean she was just they had nothing to do
like yeah I mean like okay you know how
I'm reporter Chum
she's a real morning O'Neill yeah I got
yeah that made no sense
Zangief was no Charlie Charlie was
really useless but they here's the thing
all the characters were useless mm I
guess Mortal Kombat treated thee I will
say this
Mortal Kombat treat
the characters with more respect which I
legitimately like except for Johnny Cage
who was stupid
ah but Johnny get okay and Sonia who
completely is useless at the end so
Sonia got stupid kinda cool a mother
she's gonna K knows kind of stupid okay
it can treat it half the characters with
respect I can't think of a single
character in Street Fighter that I
thought was treated with respect respect
yourself I'm afraid my barrage Julie who
is so amazing it's amazing because he's
being so goofy yeah I'm not as clearly
as I'm gonna do whatever I want I'm
Brown jr. the desperation in trying to
fit all these characters in it's like it
it's it'll it turns into rat race at the
end it's like twenty characters I think
somewhere shoehorned in to this climax
like it just I just feel like oh God any
screenwriter could have just done better
you know two fellows that work instead
of it right a street fighter movie get
every legal character in there give them
all a line at least and also sort of
like if you can a character arc you know
cuz even characters like a DJ has a
character are kind of hey you're right
about the lights okay I'm gonna turn the
exposure for you this is this is this is
what happens when we pick on Brown I
guess so
no he'll say it I had no I might you
know yeah everybody actually good
everybody he had a character arc none of
them were good they were so desperate in
the way like was it who's the green guy
Blanca yeah yeah like be in Blanca and
Dalton like wow that was Dalton but they
didn't tell me ya know at the very end
somehow like he's a decided I'm yeah my
clothes were no over the bald now and
I'm like I have decided now that I'm
going to become a yogi or something but
wow fuck did I come
if you have no is a romance between
black widow and all like get more set up
than that act and act about uh nowhere
in Avengers 2 that's a bit very similar
the more I think about it is I don't
know we've decided we're in love
yeah um but ya know it just was dull
that's my biggest problem with the movie
outside of raúl juliá who's having a
good time everybody else just don't you
know I I'm wondering what like you know
I know Sanjeev the guy points Anki very
like he is just like you know we're the
bad guys is just so one no he's so
delightfully OneNote and he's just
clearly putting a whole thing behind
shadaloo like I'm just like really
Zangief in DJ these are your minion yeah
I love hearing this incredibly powerful
advice ago tjj play me some tunes
you don't even don't stop going if
nobody knew if you went in not knowing
that Street Fighter was a game and do
nothing about it can you imagine the
reaction on something watching this
actually fucking ah if I didn't know
Street Fighter was a game it may
actually make it better cuz I may just
be like what the hell is yeah this is a
total mental yeah um I think the guy
like who wrote diehard like wrote and
directed this movie which is just like
okay well let's okay let's be honest
here there's some problems to begin with
which is you can't shoehorn that many
characters in you can't keep them in
those costumes and really take it that
seriously and I'm sure the studio was
giving notes left and right I'm sure
that script went through a ton of I was
gonna say I refuse to believe that the
guy who directed die hard and or roll
around it yeah the guy who wrote the
script for die hard I refuse to believe
that that was the kiss vision yeah and
fiercely there was the vision he was
proud somebody tampered with it or he
just got stuck in a Rodney's is like I
don't know the hell I'm doing anymore
like I've got these Garrick colorful
characters when he's like
all right I'll do this I'm not proud but
it's a page a yeah at some point you
just like you know he's just doing this
and like either so many things are going
wrong or so many changes to be made so
obvious controlling just warmer than
Napoleon had to go through or maybe like
we're all Julia maybe he had kids and
did it for his kids and thought he was
making a decent kids movie I don't know
that's or me a lot of things get set up
for failure when you have to say the
words I did it for my kids
Oh Robert Rodriguez moving something
that's something lost in space I
remember hearing the commentary for that
and he was talked about I want to make a
movie about fathers and sons and bring
families together and make a movie for
kids in this abandoned that meant
something and I'm like dude like sorry
about your relationship with your father
and like more power to you but this
movie blows and that's always a case
like I want to do somewhere my kids is
like I think the only time I saw
something were somebody's like I wanted
to make a kids movie recently that I
thought it really worked out was um
freaking Hugo I'll guess are you a I did
Goodfellas yeah the better kids movie
than a few no but hey some of these
people who like you know what to do a
film for their kids you know I I'm not
sure what the hell to even say about
Street Fighter like it it's such a goofy
stupid I mean it was dumbass idea was it
have guile being the main character mmm
come on - knockoff it oh and the whoever
even picked him like when you play the
game some Kumu no no he's a character
that was so bad that I think they
actually Jerry Riggs some of his moves
to be like slightly more powerful than
other characters and you want me to
balance it out this is sonicboom
sonicboom
that guys but uh no did not have they
had a great theme he goes with
everything this movie would have been a
lot better they put is it okay I give
you that once again like Mortal Kombat
great soundtrack you know I will say
that the one thing I really enjoy and
this is just it likes everything around
and bison in terms of like the guy
playing him his outfit I legitimately
love that outfit ah it is so silly it's
so silly but it's also it still has
this you may emerge a museum bison
outfit still wasn't quite as silly as
well Julian cuz we're all Julia
commanded respect as an actor oh it's
one of those things where no no imagine
can you imagine putting Orson Welles in
an actual Optimus Prime like other and
transformers outfit like okay can you
imagine that like that is the equivalent
of what they did with RAL Julian that's
why it's so amazing but it's not just
that it's his little desk that flies
around it's all the TV setup angle which
nowadays looks like really cheap and low
budget but back then it was kinda like
it's a pretty kick-ass evil lair like a
fucking walk this evil everything's
metallic doors open it feels like a
hostage is will die hello how you doing
down there will be blood you know bison
hi whatever our signal is oh I still
can't believe of course caught up I'm
just think of that dumb running joke
ahead everyone's like you doing of
course I fucking love that it's like I
just wonder if like one piece earnings
we have no idea how yeah cuz they I did
drive into the ground don't get me wrong
dude but by all people like occasionally
at cons will come up to Doug be like of
course yeah I mean like they'll a QA
system we had no idea what we wrote it
all you know honestly I'm just wondering
like anyone like when they shot that
scene of just him turning and saying of
course yeah you know I mean just a
little whatever scene suddenly is like
this big internet meme of line items
later with like yeah be all over the
internet and it's Soviet know when you
type in like you know of course or and
bison like that so well the first day
those two always connect on Google all
right Cattleya mintages we did it I
guess they're trying but welcome round
Julia your name man your good name is
Ben preserve oh we're terrible people I
yeah no I guess my problem is all the
characters I ended up picking like you
had Vega you and Blanca you had chun-li
you had Honda
uhh Riu know like they'll and them kind
of like side characters in this movie
I'm like why given the main characters
like to stupid people ya know we really
wanted to see people yeah um bison was
the only one that I'm just like okay I
could watch him all day but certainly
not guile can he like really they put
Cammy it's moving well you like it
Chumley at least it's like okay that'd
be an interesting main character you
know but Maki under thunder-thighs is
amazing okay dear just chun-li in my
present no no but I was like she would
be a good main character and then they
just like I said I don't care you do
even if you want to even if you want to
do some revenge story with chun-li I
would have been fine with that if they
just focus more on that instead of all
the other like I didn't freaking need
guile of course I did try to do a movie
which other fucking kidding me you how
epic I'll start you Jamaican oh just
like you know we're just like Ted scam
artists listen boys you're lucky the
good guys I don't know come on stir to
feel like the bad guys here brah funny
cop it
yeah is there like the main kid that
pretty much that is Street fire when I
think of Street Fighter I tend to think
like m.bison ken Ryu and um - Chumlee
really tend to think that and then I
start going to Blanca and you know
occasionally like Vega and like some of
the villains in but yeah like I don't
think I like cami I just you know I just
realized uh gently in this movie am I
wrong like she builds up she really
wants this revenge honestly probably
more than even gal guy was just like
he's a pot and I hate him you know but
jelly has a legitimate reason to want to
get revenge to this guy but and I hit
him is wicked cut like does she ever get
like anything fulfilled or anything
satisfying terzano and a zombie pelvis
is easiest ass excuse to put her in the
outfit so and neck and I am not
complaining
you know what cuz at least I got that
there was nothing else in the movies but
like yeah I'm trying to think wow this
pretext is really beyond fucking flimsy
but all of it my effing guy like
something words like he's a terror sandy
whatever killed my buddies right he has
brung I'm gonna get blind whatever but
it's like she has much more reason to be
pissed off at this guy she has much more
of a story to at least explain when
tomorrow's story and I'm thinking like
does she ever have like a battle or a
fight or anything with them bison like
yeah that's my problem with the movie
and I'm okay I will give Mortal Kombat
this I don't even give it that because
we're a movie called Mortal Kombat they
weren't so big on the mortal part most
of them seem to survive um but I will
give at least this bet there is
combating going on there's something
called Street Fighter remember any
street fighting like anywhere fucking I
mean turn to the game at least had two
dudes you can
oh like how hard is it to have a Street
and had two people find on it come on
this is not rocket science writes itself
that's like every Jackie Chan movie ever
made
come on did he do a movie called Street
I don't think I ever had a Madden game
but then anyway I yes he did no we did
you'll tell us oh okay hey anything else
if you want to say I do love changed the
channel i thought that i do love tuesday
I love my like I like the fake money
like there's a few funny things in it I
just it's just so silly
how can you just give me it didn't know
who I don't think I knew who was a even
more supportive comment I don't think I
knew who it was aimed for it's like this
is aimed at teenagers adults who want an
action movie or little kids or little
kids I mean a little kid yeah it feels
like a movie aimed like at seven years
old buddies it's like pg-13 right it's
not PG I guess I'm not sure I don't know
why would be pg-13 I can't really throw
in like a sex right you know it's like
Batman Rob and like clearly for kids but
you throw in like it I'll grab your rock
okay listen
and this is what bothers me about a lot
of pg-13 movies particularly in that era
was pg-13 was a trick to get teenagers
about our age between ages of 12 to 18
and to thinking this movie was gonna be
a little more badass and it wasn't
that's what Mortal Kombat did you know
as you Morecambe
was worse because that should have been
just a hard arm now seems to be peed you
know that's the new light but yeah but
like Fiji 13 in that era did a lot of
that where it's like well we'll throw in
a reference here there it's pg-13 18 me
and then you watching your little melody
you'll be this is a PG film yeah just
look like two references that are
usually groaners you know and we came
out of the 80s where pg-13 was
practically a hard-on yeah we're PG the
old PG was pretty much what p.m. Roger
Rabbit was fuckin PG and that's like who
you're sort of on the board yes blue
beat red yeah I mean it's just a fucking
design I'm like I don't know I mean okay
you need a parent in the room I guess
but I'm not on that way but yeah so it
that bothered me about Street Fighter
because you if you label something pg-13
if it what what's pg-13 I almost
positive it was yeah if you label that
but it shouldn't feel like a PG movie
yeah oh that's how I'm saying you know
hey boss if I were both upset about
these visible comedy pg-13 but for
entirely different reasons yeah Street
Fighter was pg-13 and it should have
been PG Mortal Kombat was pg-13 DiNardo
yeah so um yeah it's uh yo gay movies
still mostly suck yeah uh Matt Lee spent
Mike White Street Fighter bad ugh at
least I don't a street fighter is pretty
bottom of the barrel yeah I mean but but
it is means kind of a normal combat this
much it made the attempt yeah we thought
everything much more than that what is a
street fighters it's like I'm not even
saying like I've ever just lack of
trying to take itself as a serious
product yeah okay clearly is not doing
that which not that it's easy to do but
it's you're not big dumb like animes and
stuff like that I've done okay they just
embrace you hit you fucking marbles
Avengers and all these goofy movies can
take themselves too seriously be really
good is to fire Ken you know I'd love to
see like a video game movie that's given
kind of like the Marvel treatment where
they just fucking embrace it like the
changes are clever smart changes um but
not yet a little stop to wait and see
I love the weight
so morale Julia less muscles from
Brussels sounds good to me
wicked kick of course